so just few words about myself working
for IBM for about four years more on
data science on the software stack for
our latest data warehouse appliance so
something physical but I'm also doing
research in theoretical machine learning
at Polytechnic opposed 90s car and when
I have a little bit of time I try to
bring both worlds together to try to
solve new problems and today I will talk
about data pipeline hyper parameter
optimization which is kind of a
crossover between something that we're
doing in machine learning it's really a
standard hyper parameter optimization
and something that we're not doing in
data science at least not for the data
pipeline which is the hyper parameter
optimization so my speech will be broken
down into two parts
maybe so first I will talk about
hyperparameters optimization in general
so is everyone familiar with the hyper
parameter optimization yeah okay so
don't worry because the the first part
is about the main techniques and the
main framework for the state of art in
hyper parameter tuning and the second
part will be talking about applying
these techniques for data pipeline
optimization and the main empirical
results so if you want to go for lunch
earlier you can as the fact that if we
apply these techniques to were data
pipeline operations that all the time
have some hyper parameters or some
choices that the data scientist has to
make we can greatly improve the accuracy
of the final model in this example and I
will present you a small proof of
concepts other results will be published
soon we can increase the accuracy by
about 10% for some methods like neural
network which represent a decrease in an
error by more than 60 65 68 % if you if
you do the computation so this is
absolutely not something that we should
neglect in practice so before talking
specifically about this problem let's
talk a little bit about hyper parameter
tuning
so maybe the most example and what hyper
parameter
tuning is important is gradient descent
so a lot of machine learning algorithm
with will actually solve an optimization
problem using a gradient based descent
algorithms which is an iterative
algorithms that will look towards the
gradient direction and this algorithm
has one hyper parameter or several
actually but let's let's simplify to one
which is the learning rate and the
learning rate will determine how much
you will go toward the step of the
gradient and in the in the best cases
you will converge really fast in few
iteration and find your local optimal so
this is the functional G that you would
like to optimize but if you are taking a
too small learning rate then you will it
will you will still converge but it will
take so much time that maybe in practice
it's untrackable I mean you don't have
enough CPU time to do that and on the
contrary and even worse if you have too
large one you have a phenomena called
overshooting and your algorithm will
totally diverge so you will never be
able to learn anything and to minimize
your function so there is a trade-off to
fine and this trade-off you cannot learn
it directly from the data but still it
is depending on the data so the we will
see how we can find this data this exact
value for this parameter so usually what
you are doing is you will pick some
random configuration and you will
generate model and learn a new model
with this and you will validate it using
your validation process very often a
cross validation and you will select at
the end the configuration and toss the
model that gives you the best metric in
this example the accuracy so the state
of farts
instead of art in terms of hyper
parameter tuning is a framework which
sequential model based optimization or
SM Bo you can also find it under the
name smack sequential model based
algorithms configuration I give one
reference that is using this and it's
the most up-to-date so probably this
word will we
be the new trend instead of SMB oh so
for SMB oh what do you need you need a
configuration space over which you will
search for your configurations for your
parameters you need a metric to optimize
which is the metric of your model
usually the model accuracy or something
a little bit more evolved depending on
your problem you need the most important
part is the surrogate model that you
need so the surrogate model is a kind of
approximation of your objective function
so you would like to optimize a
functional that is usually really hard
to approximate and it's kind of a black
box so you will build a surrogate that
will be much easier to optimize you also
need a criteria to know the next
promising configuration that is to say
well I know that if I increase slightly
my learning rate I expect better results
so this is this kind of rules and this
kind of criteria and you need a history
of information so all the configuration
that you already explored which is
usually in this basic form the history
of score and configuration explored so
let's review really fast few techniques
of hyper parameter tuning so the basic
things that you can do is simply use a
grid search so you will have several
possible points that represent
configuration you will simply look for
make an exhaustive search and look over
all those points of course this is in
practice intractable if you ever try
this you know that if you have I don't
know just let say 10 parameters with 10
different values 10 to the power of 10
if you were trying to optimize neural
network it's absolutely impossible
another problem is what's a what tells
you that your discretization is good
maybe your learning rate the range
between too short and too large learning
rate will be in between the two points
that you use sample for your grid so you
don't know that of course we have common
knowledge we're sharing papers and
configuration so we can reuse this
knowledge but it is not sure sure thing
so here is simply a small example of
implementation with like it learn if
you're using for prototyping you can all
use it to make high-performance or
tuning really fast so you define your
classifier here random forest you define
your grid three parameters value
choosing more or less arbitrarily or
with my knowledge and then you simply
use a grid search with the
cross-validation here just an but you
can put stratify sampled or any kind of
other techniques slightly more evolved
techniques consists in looking randomly
into your space of configuration well
it's slightly better because then you
don't have this problem of grid and you
can sample your whole space still it's
not really intelligent and you can spend
a lot of time just finding the right
configuration and also once you find a
nice configuration what tells you that
you will explore just around and tells
you what is the best configuration
around you cannot do that because you're
never using any history or any past
information we have slightly more
advanced technique using quasi random
sequences but still it doesn't solve the
problem so to do the the implementation
with scikit-learn well it's it's exactly
the same as for grid search you simply
replace grid search by randomized search
cross-validation so this is another way
of doing it really really fast if you
have a prototyping something with a very
small search grid search I mean
informations space of configuration
sorry you can simply simply use random
search then comes iterated local search
in this case you will simply use the the
past points you know in which direction
you're looking so you basically have a
neighborhood and you will look in which
direction you would like to to go and
you explode evaluate these
configurations and you select the one
that is the most promising or gives you
the best iteration the problem of this
is that of course you can find local
optimum so you need to have a
perturbation process that sometimes will
let you go out and transfer you in
another part of your configuration or
search space so we have some proofs it
can give you the optimal global optimal
but it can be really really fast and and
that's something that is still used
really used so I can recommend one
implementation which is furn
I
it's in rugby not in Python but it
doesn't matter because it's just a
wrapper on top of your program so you
can't you can test it by yourself and
the latest techniques there are some
others but there are not into this
framework of smack its Bayesian
approaches which is kind of the state of
art for smack optimization so you have
the surrogate model that you want to
optimize is this probability the
probability that you will obtain a
certain accuracy knowing the hyper
parameter configuration so while you are
looking for new parameters and exploring
configuration you will remember your
whole history of configuration and score
and you will estimate this this
probability distribution in order to
look for the next point such that it
will give you the maximum expected
improvement on your accuracy so there
are several types of regression you can
do like Gaussian regressions like it's
the case here but you have plenty of
other techniques depending on on your
parameters and there are plenty of
implementation Spira means robo hype
erupt bias opt I'm just giving you an
example with the hyperope because this
is what I used in practice so you simply
define an objective function that
returns you while the cross-validation
score in my case accuracy on the random
forest you define your search space a
little bit the same as before for
scikit-learn just the syntax is slightly
different and you can simply start the
minimization process and at the end you
will obtain the best score the best
model and the best configuration for
your algorithm okay so this is the state
of art in hyper parameter tuning this is
something that in academia we're doing
all the time but also in practice we
have plenty of well it's industry really
it's developed in the industry as you
might probably use them already but now
we will talk specifically about data
pipeline optimization and this is
something that I've never seen anywhere
and I was looking actually it's a
problem I faced during my PhD because I
I need
to to collect a huge huge data set and I
needed to pre-process this data for my
algorithms to be able to generate any
any any prediction any model and the
problem I faced is that I realized that
there are so many choices on the way I
can pre-process my data and I have no
information whatsoever how I can really
get the best out of this data for my
algorithms to you to provide me the best
result so this is why I started to be
interested in this I found a small
serving on the internet it was on cackle
this year and the question was what is
the most annoying and the most
difficulty that you face at your daily
job as a data scientist and the first
answer is dirty data and I was kind of
surprised but not surprised at at some
time maybe you would say exactly the
same here if you if you're working and
as data scientists but my question was
if we know that data are so important
why are we really treating is less
seriously as the algorithms we know
right now that data are so important
even more than algorithms we have good
understanding on plenty of algorithms
even neural network deep learning we
starts to understand how they work what
are their capacities but we know that
your algorithms cannot be cannot provide
you better results than the quality of
your data and my answer at first was
like for this guy to still have a job
and I think it summarized pretty well
the job of data scientists right now
there is commonly it's commonly accepted
that most of the time maybe 70 80 up to
80 percent of data scientists time spent
on pre-processing the data cleaning the
data handling a dirty data so you might
say okay so if data scientist is saying
like that's my that's my main difficulty
at job it means that it does care
it does care about the data but I'm
saying well we also do care about our
algorithms but yet we are not tweaking
everything in our machine learning
process by hand we're using hyper
parameters optimizations you find the
right parameters and the right
combination that gives you the best
results so back to the original question
when I meant what does it mean treating
seriously it means automating things
that we do not have to do by ourselves
and that a machine can do better than us
and in particular the data optimizing
data pipeline so you might be wondering
like okay but what are exactly are you
talking about so I make a small list of
questions for you so when you're dealing
with missing values what are you doing
discarding what are you discarding rows
columns imputation what type of
imputation are you replacing by the mean
median model-based what type of model
what type of hyper parameter for your
model if you haven't balanced data how
are you why is that unbalanced because
you cannot sample some of the class of
some classes of your algorithms or any
of your data distribution or it's
because that's the naturally natural
distribution of your data are you doing
down sampling over sampling or maybe
nothing
what bias does it imply if the data is
too large for your computational power
you will use probably the dimensional
reductions algorithms what type of
algorithms PCA but with what kernel I
mean linear or non-linear with what
kernel are you doing a normalization on
or are you using subsampling maybe what
technique what bias does it imply for
your data outlier detection all the time
what threshold what deviation you
measure are you using are using trimming
truncating censoring left censoring
right censoring and the list goes on and
goes on winterization maybe you have
some methods that you would like to use
or some domain requirements so are you
using discretization what type of grid
what step for your grid or maybe cluster
ization what method clustering sir what
methods what hyper parameter for your
methods and maybe cattle categorical
encoder
yeah but binary hot one Helmuth backward
differences you have so many choices and
we know that those choices depends on
your data but also in your algorithm so
how can you justify that
and finally for natural language
processing that's
what I will study on this proof of
concept how many tokens are taking and
what are the size of the engrams that
you're generating and keeping so there
are so many questions and ok when you
are asking one or two questions we have
general guidelines but when you start to
make a huge huge data pipeline this is
not that obvious
so usually the process in industry at
least looks a little bit like this and
it looks like this also in academia
because in academia it's even worse you
skip the data pipeline part before we
just take data sets already pre
processed mostly pre-processed and you
just apply your methods and say oh my
algorithm is better without taking into
account the pre-processing impact that
it might have oh you're also hiding your
own pre-processing steps that happens
very a lot so right now it looks like
this you have your raw data some
operations and you will forwards Ural
data to V algorithm through this data
pipeline then you have a meta optimizer
that will suggest some configuration P
that you will give to the algorithms
that will learn different models and
with your metric you will select the
best model and go on in production what
I suggest is to do exactly the same
thing for data pipeline you have a met
up to Mizer that will suggest some
configurations for all your operations
in your data pipeline generate plenty of
data pipelines and with a certain metric
you will select the best data pipeline
and finally forward this data to your
algorithms so okay we need a metric how
do you evaluate the best data pipeline
well by it simply a feedback a little
bit like in smart framework where we are
basing the suggestion for the
configuration on the history that we
have and at the end we want to really
optimize the accuracy right or any kind
of metric of your model but not on your
data pipeline it's just a proxy to get
the best out of your data so here is the
experiments that I've done I took 1,000
judgments document from the European
Court of Human Rights so it's like pure
text I remove the conclusions of course
and I had to grow
truth because it was already labeled the
pipeline that I set up was simply a
tokenization it's really classic stop
word removal part of speech tagging
limit ization
and then I generate the engrams and
finally I do bag of word projection and
this bag of word will be forwarded to
different algorithms so I use decision
tree neural network random forest
engineer SVM I define my search space
only with two parameters such that it's
easy to see and also very small a third
space such that I can do exhaustive 13
reasonable time so you had only the
engrams from 1 to 5 and the tokens in
the dictionary for your bag of word
projection from 10 to 100 thousand so
here are the results so this is the heat
map for each of the algorithms and you
can see that depending on the under
configuration so here you have ok we
cannot see but you can see that on the
on the column you have the number of
talk of tokens and on the line on the
rows you have the the number of engrams
that we care this is not surprising that
we obtain really bad results for only 10
and 100 tokens because we know that as
data scientist that it's a very bad idea
to summarize 1,000 documents in only 10
or 100 dimensions the most common tokens
but what is a little bit more surprising
is that if I plot a first of all we can
see that if we remove these two columns
that were like kind of the tests the the
accuracy really improves in both
directions or really change in both
directions meaning that both operations
in your data pipeline really matters I
mean the hyper parameter is in your data
pipeline so here are the best
configuration that I found and it might
be a little bit surprising because the
best configurations are not when you
have the most information meaning like
100,000 tokens and also you can have
several best configuration this is not
really surprising but you can see that
you can optimize also your time if you
check for a linear SVM only the tokens
the engrams going until 3 grams right
and now
until five because it doesn't improve
your results so here on just just the
table that I that is summarizing the the
best accuracy that you can have this is
not really important and I'm running out
of time so this is the the first table
that I've shown and you can see that if
you fix only in one direction meaning
that you will take the best the best
results when you fix n equals to one
meaning that basically you are not using
any engrams you are just using your row
tokens then you will you can improve
your results by adding this operation in
your data pipeline by five point nine
five point four to nine point eight
percent on your final accuracy of the
model meaning that you have interest
really interest in adding this operator
in your data pipeline so you can really
study the influence of each of your
operation in data pipeline and you can
optimize it such that you take the best
out of it so now I have new questions I
was wondering how much time do I have to
spend to find this optimal optimization
because if I have to spend thirty five
times more I mean more times to find the
optimal configuration I'm not really
interested right so here are the
cumulative distribution of the total the
number of configuration you have to
explore before finding the optimal the
optimal configuration and you can see
for instance it's not surprising that
for random forest a linear SVM it's it's
slower because we have three optimal
points and not only one but what is
interesting is that in the worst case in
the worst case you will still find your
best configuration much faster than with
exploring every configure every possible
configuration okay here it's not so so
much if you take a look at decision tree
neural network you can do it in 31 or 33
and the best I mean the worst case is 35
configuration that we have this is due
to the fact that the search space is so
small that we cannot really evaluate the
surrogate model but I have much much
better results on large search space and
you
in few configuration obtain something
that is really near to the optimal
configuration and also you can give me
some bounds I tell you with 50%
probability how much do you think I need
to explore my configuration space and
spend time to find the optimal
configuration and the answer is like
well that's approximately 8
configuration so I can tell you that you
have 50% chance to to find in any
configuration the best configuration ok
but I have another question how can i
quantify if an optimal configuration is
algorithm specific meaning I would like
to transfer my knowledge something that
I learned what is the optimal
configuration for my data pipeline is
that specific to the algorithm that I'm
testing random forests or linear SVM or
that specific to my data and data
pipeline together this is really
important because if it's specific to
your data pipeline it means that
whatever is the algorithms you will use
you you you don't have to start this
search again and again you can transfer
this knowledge so for this I created one
procedure that is based on the mean
absolute deviation which measure for a
reference point how much the pounds are
rounds are in a given samples are far
from it
and if you normalize it by the number of
dimension in your configuration space
you can actually compare between
different configuration space in let's
say not unfair way
so for each optimal configuration that
you obtain on your plenty of algorithms
and algorithms you will build a sample
such that you will take the optimal one
optimal point by algorithms that is the
closest from your reference point you
will express everything in a normalized
configuration space normalized because
as you've seen I have one axis that is
from 1 to 5 and the other from 10 to
10,000 so I still want to account for
the first axis and then I will calculate
this n mod
and not nmap indicator so the ID so on
the small example that I've shown you
you can see on the first one table for
the expression of every optimal point in
in the space in the normalized space
then you can see also the sample how how
they are built and the ID why we're
taking only 1 point per cluster is that
per algorithm is that let's assume that
you have two optimal points in in blue
for the first algorithms and three for
the second algorithm you can see that
probably you have a cluster here so you
don't want to check this point into
account when you're calculating the
dispersion you want only two to account
for the closest one because otherwise it
seems a little bit unfair to say that
this at this point is far from this one
well it's really really close to you
have an optimal value that doesn't
depend so much on the algorithm that's
the basic idea and the results that we
obtain so the the idea of doing this
test was on the small test on a small
data set with few points was simply to
be able to observe if this indicator is
given is giving the the same results as
we would explain and we will interpret
as human right and this is the case
because if you take the first one you
have zero and this is really really
obvious because if you take this sample
so you can see this point one and zero
five is an optimal point for all my
algorithms meaning that well the
distance in the sample is zero and it
means that well it's kind of Universal
good point for my data pipeline at least
for this sample of algorithm but when I
take the point in in the in green then
you can see that they still are really
close to these blue points that are
accounts for for a lot so the N and Matt
indicator is still quite like small but
for the red points you start to see that
you have
higher-value because you starts to be
further than the other points in optimal
points in your configuration space so
the future work actually work in
progress that is that is done and
submitted as the like test and larger
configuration spaces where you cannot
visualize and you cannot also calculate
the optimal value just because they are
much bigger we have some spaces of
configuration that are 10 to the power
of 100 these kind of things so of course
you cannot look directly for each
configuration and also we would like to
optimize the data pipeline generation
itself meaning not only you give me a
data pipeline and I'll give you the
optimal configuration for it but also if
you should put or not these operations
and trying to build it from scratch and
also to find the right order because
sometimes the pre-processing steps are
order dependent so well that's concluded
that concludes the talk so now I guess
you're welcome for feeding my ideal
generator pipeline ok thank you so much
one shirt question yet there's one thank
you so much I just wanted to ask if you
had certain procedures to for example
determine if a pipeline configuration
that she used is actually better not
just from the point of the score but if
you do any statistical tests on it for
I've see very often that the you know
traditional parametric tests tend to
fail at actually discovering the
differences they tend to be not
sensitive enough to because distribution
still not be normal and now I was
wondering what does the use or if the or
if does it even matter when you have so
much there it depends it depends on the
on the algorithm and on the pipeline I
took on purpose on pipelines and some
algorithms I fixed the the seed
generation grain for for the algorithm
and the data pipeline has no randomness
whatsoever in it
meaning that it doesn't really matter
for for this purpose but I I agree that
it's something to be studied because I
cannot just say like okay I got I got
like I can't remember the figure but 9.8
percent improvement in accuracy if you
do not fix the the seat for your neural
network and for the data pipeline so
there is of course something to do when
you you are in production and you
actually that you know the sense the
variation of accuracy or your metric is
not due to the fact that you obtains you
have another seed and you're really
lucky on that but that is really duty to
the optimization but this is already in
the in the smart framework meaning that
by using optimization you I over
simplified the framework but basically
it will assess
it will do a step that is called
intensifying and it will look in an area
that looks promising
it will repeat possibly several times
the Samsung configuration just to sample
this distribution and I have an idea how
the data all your algorithms behave
there so the idea would be to do the
same thing for your data pipeline well
yes yeah yeah so I guess still it's
valid to fix the the city you have an
idea on that and yeah there are more
work to do to do on that for sure okay
thanks so much opposed please
[Applause]